hi everybody thanks for coming and we
have a probably limited amount of time
which so it seems to us because
journalists like to go on and on so
we're going to try to move very quickly
i want to say at the outset the question
procedure is as follows if starting
right now a question occurs to you raise
your hand at the moment at which the
question occurs to you someone will rush
over and get it in written form and then
at about eleven it'll come up though the
questions will come up here and i'll
start reading the questions added to the
panelists i believe i read them out
without the questioners name attached so
let that be in your thinking as you
decide on formulating questions i want
to start by introducing richard sambrook
who is going to show a short film clip
and just the only thing I'll say as
introduction to his film clip is we as
journalists are in a paradoxical
position here and we're going to explore
some of these paradoxes the paradox is
roughly this everybody in the university
starting very much with Lee is
increasingly interested in globalization
and that's essentially why this event is
taking place our dream is that the
university can be a truly international
institution and that the work of the
university is truly international in its
nature and certainly our school and I
think every other person on this stage
today would say that his or her school
is becoming more international in every
possible way now the paradox is
journalists who occupy the key role of
sort of intermediary between people in
power people with ideas conflict all the
things going on in the world that aren't
ready at your fingertips and the general
public we should be the most globalized
if what we are is information purveyors
the information we should we purvey
should be a kind of common carrier that
lays down a basis of facts and analysis
that everyone can agree on and they can
have the debate but that that died okay
Nick thanks very much to get the the
discussion going I asked the BBC's
monitoring department to take one day's
news and international story and compare
and contrast how some different channels
around the world reported it and the day
I think was September the 10th today the
General Petraeus made his report on the
state of affairs in Iraq and as you'll
see as we compare and contrast the the
way that report was covered by a range
of different global channels from the
u.s. to Europe the Middle East there's
some interesting differences of the
merger perhaps we can then we want to
talk about so as you can play the tape
yes the top American commander in Iraq
recommended cutting US troops in the
country by about 30,000 by the summer of
next year the general told a joint
hearing of the House of Representatives
Armed Services and foreign affairs
committees in Washington that the
security situation was improving in his
view America's current surge of troops
was meeting its military objectives
international TV news channels each had
their own angle on the story BBC World
lunchtime bulletin reported that an
opinion poll carried out by the BBC
found that the majority of Iraqis
disagreed with the u.s. generals views
they did not believe security had
improved nearly a quarter of Iraqis now
say things are very bad compared to one
in ten two years ago two-thirds
disapprove of the way the Iraqi Prime
Minister Nouri al-maliki is handling his
job seventy percent say the US troop
surge has made
worse sixty-eight percent say there has
been forcible separation of sunny and
shears in areas where they used to live
together reporting live from Baghdad BBC
World correspondent Lee's de said said
the government there welcome the report
we had the first official reaction in
the government statement read by the
national security adviser wafik all
revive he welcomed that the reports made
by both General David Petraeus and also
ambassador Ryan Crocker and he didn't
actually comment directly on general
Petraeus's comment that by the summer
they could return to what they call pre
surge levels that means 30,000 american
troops leading by next summer but the
national security adviser did say that
he could see that in the near future as
he put it that I rocky forces would be
able to carry out combat operations
without calling on the coalition forces
Iraqi state television ally rakia
carried the US generals testimony live
it featured as the third item in its
flagship evening news bulletin the
channel highlighted the generals views
that the Iraqi Armed Forces were
performing better it also interviewed an
Iraqi government spokesman who said the
report was positive and reflected the
real situation in Iraq it dispelled the
idea of a civil war spokesman said most
pan-arab TV channels had live coverage
of General Petraeus in Washington al
Jazeera the most-watched of the pan-arab
stations devoted several of its talk
shows to the story it interviewed an
exiled Israeli are abundant accused the
u.s. of fueling sectarian differences in
iraq wap fe al jazeera also ran box pops
of iraqi refugees in Syria by land
Iraqis in the Kurdistan Region
saudi-owned Al Arabiya broadcasting from
Dubai interviewed its own us affairs
expert who said some Democrat members of
Congress disputed general Petraeus's
credibility and independence a guest on
al arabi as daily talk show Sunni iraqi
leader sally ellenwood luck said the
report played down violence in iraq well
I letter
regrettably this report does not match
the size of daily sacrifices made by the
Iraqi people it does not match the
amount of blood that He shed daily the
u.s. global TV news pioneer CNN let its
bulletin with general Petraeus's remarks
in Washington the tribal rejection of
al-qaeda that started in on bar province
and helped produce such significant
change there has now spread to a number
of other locations as well based on all
this and on the further progress we
believe we can achieve over the next few
months I believe that we will be able to
reduce our forces to the pre surge level
of brigade combat teams by next summer
without jeopardizing the security gains
that we have fought so hard to achieve
CNN followed up with a feature about a
former Iraqi insurgent who had fought
against the coalition forces before
switching sides and now worked alongside
American troops iran's press t be an
english-language international news
channel which launched in july this year
took the line that the US Congress
rejected general Petraeus's report well
the US House Foreign Affairs Committee
has rejected the Iraq war reports given
by top US commander in Iraq David
Petraeus Committee Chairman Tom Lantos
said Petraeus and US ambassador to Iraq
Brian Crocker I only tried to convince
Congress the Washington is winning the
war in Iraq however lines also Congress
isn't buying it because it knows that
the situation in Iraq is critical now
lantus said US troops should pull out of
the country immediately france24 a
global news channel in French English
and Arabic described the testimony as
judgment day for President Bush the
channel highlighted us claims that Iran
was seeking to further destabilize Iraq
for its own interests france24 been
focused on NT us demonstrations in the
Iraqi capital
so it's a little like the story of the
blind men and the elephant Richard it
seems to me that there's one set of
questions that do you think the Warner
up is a good idea or bad idea there's
another set of questions how's it going
that are sort of fact and analysis
questions and we really see a large
degree of disagreement about that basic
question is this a problem for the press
globally is there any way to transcend
the kind of perspective ilysm that you
see in this little cave well I think
what's interesting about that is always
interesting when you make those
comparisons and as somebody who leads a
broadcast news operation disconcerting
as well I'm sure all of those
broadcasters could or would argue that
their coverage was objective in the
sense of being based on evidence or
based on facts but you can clearly see
they all have a very different framework
a very different basis of the judgments
they're making for selection of what
they highlight and what they emphasize
and the disconcerting part is that those
judgments reinforce the kind of cultural
position and indeed the political
positions a lot of the countries and
cultures that they come from absolutely
including the BBC and CNN as well to a
greater degree than I think anybody
would any of them would have commit
without having that evidence laid out in
front of them so I mean I think that one
of the challenges for us as we move into
a global environment for journalism and
we're living an unprecedented era for
global journalism is almost a new global
channel every month that we got the
internet and so on as well is the global
conversation you know can we establish a
kind of solid foundation of fact if you
like of how the wars going from which
you can then have an opinion about
whether it's a good or a bad thing or
actually is even that foundation subject
to cultural interpretations to a
worrying degree so answer the question
you just pose what do you think and if
it's the first how do we do it I think
we need a
foundation and we have to continue to
work at it and I think it's probably a
lot more difficult than many of us are
prepared to recognize let me turn to you
next Deepak tell us a little about how
the Iraq war is playing in Turkey and in
particular how to the country and to you
personally as a broadcast journalist the
rise of Al Arabiya his chairman al
Jazeera has changed life I think we have
to look back and go back to 2003 when
the first u.s. operation was being
planned and there was the sense in the
US administration that the Turkish
Parliament was going to give a go-ahead
for using its soil for the operation and
a lot of the plans were made accordingly
and then the public opinion was
completely against this and it didn't
pass in Parliament and i would say that
in in general in turkey we feel that
this is an aggression towards the Iraqi
people that it could have been handled
better and we see now no end to the
conflict which will be which is in size
and the other thing it was mentioned in
the news the sectarian violence we are
very much worried about so i would say
that though as turks we increasingly use
the internet so our source of
information is not necessarily local
channels we increasingly use global
networks we have subsidiaries of global
networks like CNN wii u wii a lot of
people get BBC and now al jazeera this
is shaping the Turkish discussion on the
matter but I would say most of the
Third's they rely on local channels for
their source of information it's mostly
the Intelligencia and the newspapers
that follow the global networks and
through them the informations gets
disseminated so if you were to watch
this day just in the panoply of Turkish
broadcast media including al Jazeera
since it's available there what would
you blood most likely have seen of white
as wider range is this you know you
would see the old
active reporting about his testimony
that would be you know he said XYZ but
probably more closer to al-jazeera I
would think by the way is yet another
one of these new interesting issues we
have a recent alum one of my students
who worked for Al Arabiya who told me
that they've been told that they cannot
go beyond saying there was death due to
sectarian violence on the air they
cannot say who killed him in the
particular incident because of a fear
that they'll be revenge killings
motivated by that so she feels like all
the things we taught her at Columbia
Journalism school she can't put into
play because if she does it will cause
people to be killed another set of
paradoxes Mike you're currently running
the International Herald Tribune which
of all the folks in the media should be
immune to this it's and forgive me
pretty elite and put the publication
with a pretty global perspective or at
least a Western European perspective do
you have to worry about this or can you
sit down in your news media and say okay
let's all agree on how things are going
in Iraq this this is our daily challenge
Victor worried about this every day you
know we as journalists face a whole set
of challenges in the world the way it's
changing now technological challenge
business challenges physical challenged
to our own safety in many parts of the
world but the challenge of rising above
our own paradigms of being bigger than
our own biases is I think the essential
journalists challenge challenge always
has been and probably always will be but
it has become more and more pressing I
think in the world we now live in and it
is more and more our obligation to our
own audiences in many ways I have life
easier than most newspaper editors and
television broadcasters around the world
because I at least have an audience all
over the world and I can't pander and
cater to anyone national perspective
where I lose the bigger challenge is if
you're a national publication or a local
publication anywhere
anyways on earth the obligation you have
to your audience to portray the world
the way it really is and not just the
way your audience believes it to be is
our essential journalistic obligation
but it is a very difficult job not just
because we have our own preconceptions
but also because to bring your audience
along and to have them hear things from
you that don't fit their preconceived
notions runs the risk that you'll make
them angry or even worse than making
them angry that you'll just lose their
attention and that's the worst thing
that can have to do a journalist is to
lose your audience's attention see if
it's a very big challenge as you try to
bring your audience along to understand
the world isn't exactly the way you
thought it was before you open my
newspaper or turned on your television
set is is our essential challenge and a
task I don't think we spent nearly
enough time thinking about how to do so
just to press on enemy you work as
journalists always are very good at
posing questions since less good about
anything but how do you solve that
problem well be the next generation as
opposed to you tomorrow in any other
thing one of the things we do at the
Herald Tribune which i think is very
helpful to us and perhaps there are
virgins of this that can apply if we try
to get as many different people with
different perspectives in the process as
we can our very wonderful French
political reporter Catrin been told is
German our very excellent Berlin
correspondent Judy Dempsey is Irish and
we try to push as much as possible to
have different points of view at the
table or on the phone and force
ourselves to think differently and force
the Americans to think about the Eastern
European point of view and force our
correspondent in Istanbul to think about
mr. Sarkozy's point of view and make
them look at these issues you're never
going to be perfect but you can make it
better do you find yourself ever
thinking gee when I was in Washington
for example I really was wearing
blinders and I just didn't have a broad
enough perspective and if that's true if
you could give a couple examples of
issues that you just see differently
being here and supervising a more
international staff every single day you
see the world very differently once you
get outside the United States and I
suspect you see it differently every
time you get out of France or turkey or
anywheres else but possibly not the
United Kingdom
right man but about give you one one
very current example which is
essentially another way of looking at at
what Richard shared with us which is and
I've just come back from New York where
I spend time at the New York Times
visited our Washington bureau the Iraq
war just in terms of how important it is
looks different from outside the United
States you know in the United States it
is the all-consuming issue it's the
major political event it's the thing
that everyone in the United States
worries about that is not true in the
rest of the world it's an important
story people in the rest of the world
are worried about it they wonder what it
will mean about America's place in the
world some are rooting for it to mean
one thing and some are praying it
doesn't mean that thing but but the the
footprint that the Iraq war takes up in
the United States is far larger just to
start with that it is anywhere else on
earth except possibly Iraq itself and
that by itself is an important
journalistic point and changes the
perspective and there's an important
issue for us in terms of how much of our
time and effort is devoted in The Herald
Tribune to the war let me move to and
we'll circle back to all these things
obviously the big thing happening in
journalism is the advent of the Internet
as really well on its way to becoming
the dominant means of news provision I
think so let's all talk a little about
how that changes our lives and I'll
start with you Richard well it changes
Leisner in a number of ways I mean
firstly it's a huge technological
challenge for any news organization
there are questions of resources that
are questions of simply managing you
know how do you get your journalism onto
the internet what kind of services
should you be offering and the
technology basic technology challenges
it moves incredibly rapidly we're now
going into mobiles and so on as well so
there's a huge resource and technology
challenge but then with a bigger
challenge I think is it really is if
you're not the journalistic and cultural
one where you know you as a your role as
a news organization is fundamentally
altered and
you know our role as gatekeepers I
believe has gone now and where it's
coming of hanging on in one or two
places but fundamentally I think the
gatekeeper role is gone basic daily news
is commoditized you don't have to sit
down at six o'clock and switch on the TV
on the radio to know what's happened
that day it's all around you is on the
internet on your mobile phone it's on
screens are the bus stop it's wherever
so what is the role of the news
organization is no longer just saying
this has happened today it's our
interpretation it's about analysis and
explanation but it's also about
facilitating and hosting a conversation
and as more people you know through
technology want to take part in that
discussion of news i wanta what have
their voice heard and have more of a
stake in it then the role of a news
organization is to say we will host that
conversation and you know we'll provide
a framework for that conversation
according to our editorial values which
hopefully you will respect and get some
value back in return so talk a little
about how you're doing that and and and
what kind of audience you have on the
web what's the nature of the audience
what are the ground rules for hosting
the conversation so on let me give you a
couple of examples and I'm responsible
for the international services as a BBC
the global services we run a program
called world have your say a daily
program which goes out on the radio and
also on the internet it's like a phone
in show but it's a global one it also
brings in blog comments or whatever
topic they're discussing that day and
one of the things we've discovered for
example is we also have regional
versions of it as well but Africa have
your say which is the only place where
someone in Nigeria can speak to someone
in Tanzania about AIDS and that they
can't do it through their their national
media they can't do through any regional
media really and you get conversations
and comparisons going on across
boundaries and across cultures simply
because of the nature of the technology
that wouldn't happen otherwise so you
know our role is to host that and
provide the platform and provide some of
the values around it so another example
of that issue I suppose is
the dilemma about moderating comments on
on the on the website and as most news
organizations i think we started off by
pre moderating comments people would
email in their views and we decide which
ones to put up quickly became apparent
that wasn't good enough for the users
they didn't want us making that judgment
so we've now gone to post moderation
which means that the comments go up and
we discreet where we then read through
and take out anything that we think is
offensive or inappropriate according to
a transparent and published set of
guidelines so you know again our role is
shifting there we're there to provide a
platform for that discussion that goes
on on the way our own website but we're
no longer the people that can say you
know what we think will allow you to say
that bit or will allow you to say that
bit we have to allow the users to have
their own conversation but we can put
some values on it so you know you're not
allowed to be offensive if you're not
allowed to be racist in order to know to
the right the right kind of conversation
only to turn the matter fact huy pek so
when you go to work every day what's
your job what's your function in society
are you an information provider are you
really there just to get the highest
ratings we were discussing just
beforehand how you're a
second-generation journalist how's your
function in society generally in terms
of your daily activities different from
your father's function in society if you
could just talk about that a little i'd
like to think that people come to
journalists for a perspective in
addition to objective news reporting so
i thought what i think is the lacking
and what i try to provide is a sense of
perspective because we have observed
kind of news as commodity every day
there's more and more news available
through many different channels and the
internet you know the regular channels
bloggers emails you name it and you want
to look for credibility and reliability
but i think most of all i'm always
for perspective about historical
background to put news in context
because oftentimes people might know
what the latest announcement was but
they might not have all the resources to
put it in perspective and I think when
you're forming opinions you need some
perspective so that's how I see my role
do you think that is a view of you
shared by your audience the people trust
you and think if she said it must be
true essentially well I'd you know this
is what I'm aiming at and I think you
build credibility like that but we
cannot we cannot stop thinking about our
audience the audience is used to fast
news they want more scandalous better
more groundbreaking news so they do like
especially in Turkey this sort of
journalism so you cannot always be so
calm and and report the news and give
your opinion but I'm under the belief
that there has to be more sensibility in
the journalism world in Turkey give us
an example of a recent story that would
be a huge scandal story in Turkey that
would build a big audience and then if
you could talk about how you react to
the presumed charge you get from your
bosses to devote more airtime to that
and less to what we can all sit here in
a panel discussion and say the press
should be doing well just forgive this
is going to be just a recent example in
there is for example when I came here in
my network was very well aware that I
was going to be interviewing President
Bollinger and what's very hot about this
news is the recent development of the
speech of President Ahmadinejad at
Columbia so as a network and as my
audience probably they are very very
interested for me to really dig into
this almost in the whole time that I
have with the president whereas in my
view this is
the only thing that I want to talk about
his hobbies and we didn't get to the
hobbies I assure you but basically you
have to balance I think this kind of
enthusiasm for consuming hot news and
what it really means I was um I want to
go from that to talk about some of the
economic and structural issues that
underlies some of this discussion I was
telling Richard last night I had a an
evening guess last week where the
communications subcommittee of the House
of Lords came to the United States on a
fact-finding mission and they're going
to issue some sort of report and I was
one of a group of people they took out
to dinner at which I was feeling really
good about myself for having been
invited until Richard told me well
nobody pays attention to the House of
Lords anymore but up to that point it
was very heady experience the at one
point in the evening I said to them you
know it's arguable that the leading news
organization in Britain is in some sense
a government agency I know you're not
really a government agency and you have
many firewalls and Chinese walls and
other forms of protection but
nonetheless there's the licence fee that
enables what I'm sure is the biggest
news gathering organization in the UK
and probably the biggest in the world
are in competition to be and
interestingly all the folks that the
nurse said oh yes but that's anomalous
we couldn't even have a conversation
about the House of Lords today I mean
about the BBC today because it's a relic
of the socialist past of Britain and you
can't get rid of it but you would never
establish it in a sense it's an extreme
case although it's an honorable extreme
case and I often present this to
audiences of America
journalist just as a sort of puzzle and
say what if you could levy attacks and
create a totally protected news
organization that actually did a great
job and they always say they were coil
and they say no you could never do that
because it would be a violation of the
First Amendment so let's start with this
is some sort of direct state support of
journalism a good idea well what do you
mean by stay so I'm going to jump in let
me say what i mean by states before i
mean you can have everything from
completely state dominated media like
Pravda in the good ol days or you can
have a sort of protected space such as
you enjoy but nonetheless there's a very
strong at least financing mechanism to
the state or you can have nonprofits
will in the US which have a
tax-advantaged implied subsidy or you
can have a structure like national
public radio in the united states well
is this something we should be talking
about there are definitely in my view
and I mean the crucial point about the
BBC the advantage we have is a very
strong funding base but it is a complete
anachronism who would never be invented
again but the most crucial thing about
it are those fireballs which are very
explicit set out in the Constitution are
kind of patrolled and fought over almost
daily in some ways but the BBC's
independence is absolutely crucial or
without that we're nothing our
credibility in our trust and our
standards come from being able to
protect that independence and every so
often we have a huge rail with the
British government over some issue or
other which for us is fundamentally
about that independence and therefore I
think when you say a state funding it
has to be recognized that that it would
have to be state funding without
independence embedded in it and I can't
see many governments committing the kind
of level of state funding again and
that that complete editorial freedom to
an organization in that sense I think
the BBC is an anachronism now whether
there may be other forms of funding I
don't know one of the things I've always
wondered about the the u.s. is you know
there are many very well-endowed
foundations and so are very concerned
about it high quality and independent
media and yet there isn't the equivalent
of what we have with the Guardian the
Scotch trust for example which is an ad
a mob which gives a newspaper some
freedom to have it has a particular
political position in the Guardians case
but nevertheless to support high quality
journalism that is a different model and
I do think there is an issue that
actually the market alone there are one
or two honourable exceptions he's not
going to protect high quality serious
journalism of the kind that we need in
order to have the kind of global public
debate that we're clearly going to going
to have to have in it's very complicated
well we're entering so just depress you
a little if somebody came to you and
said now what if we just cut the
umbilical cord and abolish to the
licensing flea fee and have you operate
on the American model I assume you would
not say great that's what I've always
wanted my whole life oh no I certainly
wouldn't under some of my colleagues
might enjoy it but I know I said I
certainly wouldn't want that I mean I
think if that happened the BBC could be
a very successful commercial broadcaster
but the nature of its programming would
change completely we would be producing
programming to drive ratings to serve
advertisers and our choices about
commissioning and programming will be
made on a completely different basis so
we'd be very completely different
organization Mike the New York Times has
been in an interesting position here
there's a fund manager at morgan stanley
who's sort of gun hammer and tongs after
the company and said you are not
producing enough profits for my tastes
and and the New York Times has an a/b
struck structure that allows the owning
family that sells burgers to control it
that has made the public stockholders at
least the big ones quite unhappy it's
certainly not what we would call a
growth stock as
you may have occasion to reflect when
you look at your retirement plan we've
seen and I talked about my fee today by
the way we've seen in the United States
a lot of churn over these issues The
Wall Street Journal has just changed
hands out of the sort of benign
paternalistic family ownership of the
bankrupts to Rupert Murdoch
knight-ridder is no longer with us and
there's a general sense and and and you
know according to rumor although he's
never said it to me your publisher likes
to talk about the moose in the room as a
as a it's an image the Muslim the room
is the big obvious thing nobody wants to
talk about former times reporter now
hedge fund manager and and friend of
your publisher Steve Rattner were a very
provocative and interesting op-ed piece
of the wall street journal while back
and he came and talked at our school
about in which he said look the moose in
the room he didn't use that images that
great newspapers are just not a viable
economic model in the marketplace and we
need to think of another support system
for for them which took a lot of guts
for him to say what do you think of that
preposition here's the way I described
the moose in the room the the changing
nature of the world which is most
importantly the changing technological
nature of the world is having two huge
effects on journalism the first one is
the audience challenge it's creating for
us lets our relationship to the audience
that's what Richard was talking about
before about gatekeeping and the other
very related but profoundly separate is
the business model challenge the
internet is essentially disassembling
the hundred year old business model that
sustained great journalism not just in
the United States but in a number of
places but particularly the United
States where you know journalists would
create great journalism they would put
it in their publication or put it on
their television network they would
distribute it to a large audience
advertisers would pay large amounts of
money to reach that audience publishers
and broadcasters made great deal of
money and journalism journalists made a
decent enough living
doing that well that vicious and skinny
that virtuous circle some people might
have thought of a bitches that that
virtuous circle is collapsing it's
really breaking down and I think that's
what Steve Rattner is talking about when
he talks about the business model it's a
little bit of a strange conversation
because in fact the New York Times and
many other big newspapers are still
highly profitable companies with
substantial profit margins that in most
other industries would be the envy of
the world what this business crisis is
about particularly my poetry stock
holdings in my year retirement plan is
about the way the market values you
which is to say it values what it
believes your future to be if you look
at the new york times right now making a
lot of money in the hundreds of millions
of dollars the problem is that people
don't perceive a future i think that's
wrong I think the journalism has a
fabulous future and it's because we're
going to find the answer to the issue
that Richard pose which is we're going
to we're going to reinvent ourselves not
as gatekeepers but we're going to find
another image but it will be some kind
of combination of color commentator and
guide through the strange world of the
21st century and we will we will learn a
new role for ourselves that will be
equally profoundly important and on that
role we will build new business models
on the internet and in other ways that I
think will create equally successful
businesses but right now it's a pretty
painful and confusing period and it's
painful if you're on the business side
of media companies and it's pretty scary
if you're on the journalistic sighs can
I just pick up on that big I mean I
absolutely agree with what Mike said
that but I think the interesting thing
coming back to what you were asking me
before is in broadcasting and the
International from we have this huge
explosion of competition but none of its
profitable so france24 is half publicly
funded Russia today is funded by the
Kremlin al Jazeera's funded by the Emir
of Qatar you know I could go on all the
new entrance on the global front none of
them are profitable and actually sure
all of them would say they have some
form of editorial independence though
from the tape you may well
question that so I absolutely agree with
Mike we're busy now reinventing
journalism both in print and in the
internet and in broadcast what worries
me I suppose is that on global
journalism is whether there is something
emerged which is going to kind of
guarantee impartiality and objectivity
and those principles that you know the
Columbia believes in the BBC believes
and so on as well is there a business
model that can guarantee that and that's
the worry to me and the other word agree
completely with that and the other way
is that we as journalists you know under
all this pressure may forget what it was
we actually know how to do there is a
there is a craft called journalism and
even even and it's extremely important
craft it's the ability there's a famous
American philosopher of a hundred years
ago used to say that an editor's job was
to separate the wheat from the chaff and
print the chat and by and large I think
he had it right i mean our job is to
sort and to figure things out you know
the great German publisher Matthias
Doppler who's been a real visionary on
some of these issues talks about how
what audiences need now more than ever
is orientation in the world and that's
what we know how to do and we need to
keep remembering that that's what we
know how to do we need to find new ways
to do it we can't be gatekeepers anymore
we can't be the authoritarian voice
speaking from the Mount but we can't
lose sight of the skill we have in the
way we know how to do it because that is
of more value today than it's ever been
and we'll figure out ways to derive
business value out of that and the worst
thing we could do is let go of that in
the course of trying to adapt to these
new to these new worlds so I think the
danger of not having a business model
the danger of new kinds of ownership
that undercut our independence and the
danger that we ourselves will lose our
souls in effect by trying to adapt in
ways that are actually to give up
journalism all scare me frankly talk
about the situation with regard to all
these issues in Turkey if you would and
and culturally and structurally if you
have a continuum between pure market
pure state control with many stops in
between were you and what do you think
is the idea is that where you are or
somewhere else I think it we're talking
about power here and then we're talking
about integrity and journalism because
journalism and owning news media brings
amazing amazing amounts of power so this
to some this could be the cause for
starting on profit on profitable
ventures or continuing with them in
Turkey we have the state tradition
especially on the TV side and i would
say that all on the whole even though
it's underfunded compared to other
channels that they have kept a certain
integrity in their journalism but i
would say for the most part that the
Turkish media scene is in our pretty
private venture dominated by one very
strong group and others several other
strong group so i would say that in
turkey more and more so unfortunately
the consumer of the news the population
sees news when they see a certain piece
of news when they see a headline they
will not say oh this is what happened
they will say why did they put this
specific headline there must be a reason
why this newspaper is talking about this
in this light as opposed to something
else which could be the news so it's
kind of I think really sad for the
professional journalism for the
integrity of journalism that the
audience when they read a comment
instead of thinking about the comment
immediately thinks about the rationale
for this comment so I would say there's
a mistrust of news channels so let's
spend last few minutes before we go to
questions trying to we presented a
problem essentially and let's let's see
how far we can get toward talking about
solutions to the problem first let me
put out of a view that there is no
problem
often think the term that describes the
state of journalism at least in the US
is back to the future if you go one of
the great things about being at a
university is your perspective broadens
immediate sale the horrible truth is I
knew absolutely nothing about the
history of my own profession until I
became a Dean and I had to start
planning courses in it what I now know
is that if you went back to through most
of the 19th century most of American
journalism was a cacophony of Pollock
partisan voices when the founders wrote
the first amendment to correct me if I'm
wrong here they did not really have in
mind what we've just been talking about
and what Mike just very eloquently
stated as the ideal they had in mind the
Tom Paine's of the world who were
putting out pamphlets and and and they
should be protected so what if I were to
say there is no problem the core
function of the press is simply as a
platform for the state of the strong and
unfettered statement of opinion and
perspective and with you know global
satellite broadcasting with the internet
and so on were in the Golden Age of
journalism why isn't that true oh stop I
mean I think it's in one sense of course
it is true and when you look at the
blog's of course there are many
parallels with the pamphleteers of the
19th century and earlier than that but I
think journalism has developed and we've
learned things about journalism over the
past you know 200 years and and not
least with what Joseph Pulitzer did with
Columbia and the idea of impartiality
and the idea of what that can do to
public debate in public discourse I
think is very important and therefore
we're going through this huge disruption
driven largely by technology although
also by the president was saying kind of
economic integration around the world
and so on as well huge disruption at the
minute and we shouldn't lose the baby
with the bathwater so what we're trying
to do is to hang on to what we've
learned and what we've developed and
what's been good through that as we go
through this huge disruption it would be
very easy to cast it away
there's a lot of debate a lot of print
wasted in my view saying well you know
impartiality is dead it never really
existed let's just have this great you
know feast of opinion everywhere and
that's fine isn't it people can just
choose what they want I don't think that
is fine you know we can have a
philosophical discussion about whether
there's any such thing as the
impartiality but even if you don't
believe in it the attempt to achieve it
improves quality raises standards and
helps reinforce and support a high
quality public debate which is very
important so for me I think the
important thing is we should go through
this huge technology disruption as we
try and reinvent the future of
journalism we need to hang on to what
we've learned and what's been good and
important about that let me just press
you just one more tweaked on this which
is to raise the pointy Peck made this is
a very widely made point about everybody
who's at a university that and that is
and and you one could say the making of
this point originates in this great city
is anyone who claims to be a information
purveyor or knowledge purveyor is not to
be trusted because what they claim is
information is actually just a sort of
gussied up version of their power
position in the world what makes you so
sure you're not merely engaging in that
well there'll be plenty of people who
say we are believe me you should see my
email inbox that's you know absolutely
but the great one of the great positive
things I think that's coming through the
change we let me throw them in it is the
transparency and accountability that
follows from a lot of what the Internet
can offer and all news organizations
absolutely including the BBC even many
others as well going through quite a
painful process of cultural change I
mean let's be honest news organizations
and journalists have not been the most
accountable all the most
transparent business or profession in
the past but I think we're going to have
to be in the future and we're learning
that and understanding that and being
held to account and that's why you get
you know crises that you know CBS and
yes at the BBC and the New York Times
and so on as well but actually we do
have the ability to be truly transparent
and accountable and that will raise
standards and protect standards in the
future you know when when Tom Paine got
off that boat from from England with
nothing in his pocket except a letter
from Ben Franklin and he walked into
Philadelphia literally what what how I
almost had to be carried him because we
were so sick but entered Philadelphia
and he was hired by a local publisher in
Philadelphia in the book I've just
written in the US Constitution's
political role I describe that as the
most important hire of a freelance
writer in American history and I'm a
huge fan of advocacy writing opinion
writing I think it has it has always had
an important place and in the world of
the Internet I think increasingly has an
important place but the more there is
that I think the more important it also
is that there are people out there who
are trying to portray the world without
that agenda without the agenda of
seeking an outcome and it can never be
done perfectly and it can never be done
without some influence of your own
preconceptions or biases or power
positions or whatever deconstructionist
influence we want to apply but the role
the gem agree wholeheartedly with
Richard here's the role of journalism as
we've created it in the 20th century is
is a terrific invention and it would be
a real shame if as a result of all of
these dramatic changes we lose that it's
not an either/or you can have both you
should have both you can't help but have
both it's not a choice but you you want
to preserve both so let me just push
this my last thing before going to
audience questions and I'll start with
you a peck and this is praying you on
the spot of course what if we all agree
that this particular aspect of
journalism which of course isn't and
either or any more in the age of the
internet with
the Tom Paine aspect is somewhat
endangered for a combination of economic
structural political cultural reasons
and deserves shoring up what would work
to shore it up would it be laws passed
would it be some purely economic
solution would it be a kind of
organization of the profession and
professional education what what what
are the promising avenues to really
strengthen this aspect of journalism
that we I think we all think is a little
shaky right now regulation on this topic
but I believe in professional
responsibility I think that it depends
on the institution or the institution's
globally or within a nation to take the
necessary steps but then for example the
debate we have in Turkey on this I often
have with newspaper editors is why do
you do your front page like this where
by in my opinion some of the news
mentioned are really should not be on
the first page and they will claim that
the audience wants it this way so it's
kind of a chicken or the egg situation
whereby some people will claim the
reader of the news the observer of the
news is demanding and used to be
presented in a certain way and some
people will know it's your
responsibility to show the integrity and
the whole cohesiveness of the issue to
the to the audience so in my opinion
it's a professional responsibility and
ethics issue my it's all about the
audience the audience is is us with
that's that if that relationship that
makes us everything we are and first of
all I think we have to believe in that
we have to believe that if we stick to
what we are good at and know how to do
and stick to our professional standards
and responsibilities and we'll get
rattled by all the
is going on around us we will build big
strong loyal audiences for the kind of
journalism we all believe in and then we
will figure out over time how to build
businesses that support what we do I'm
not a you know knee-jerk opponent of
government subsidies in some cases to
that that could be part of it i think
particularly if that's one of a variety
of models it can work okay but the most
important issue here is not the business
model it's the relationship to the
audience because everything else can be
built on that later well two things
really I mean we do get the media we
deserve to the extent that you know the
tabloids in Britain are the biggest
selling newspapers a lot more people by
the Sun than by the Financial Times so
if they do get the media they deserve in
that sense but I do believe that
particularly with the internet you can
build a strong business around serious
journalism there will be a model that
emerges the other thing I'd just briefly
say is particularly in the BBC which is
as you said earlier is a basically a big
state intervention within Britain into
the media and into journalism we're
often accused of market distortion by
our commercial competitors and my
response to that is and actually
journalism left entirely to Rupert
Murdoch into one or some other big
aggressive commercial organizations is
actually the information distortion and
there is another side of the equation
that people need to take into account as
well okay and I just add a couple things
before we go to questions first of all
thank you whenever you come back to the
podium you know back when he was dealing
with really controversial issues least
write about regulation of broadcasting
his position if I can summarize a career
in one sentence was broadcast regulation
is a good thing current regulation is a
bad things I'd fair I'm curious whether
you still think that so especially now
that in the u.s. broadcast regulation is
sort of gone away or has deteriorated a
lot since you were defending it is that
a good thing and or
on the other side of the equation should
there be more state intervention in in
print journalism something the
journalists were required from in Horace
of hold that thought you know it just to
close this part of the panel it's it's
really interesting for me as a lifelong
journalist to be thinking about this in
the context of being at a university for
these last four these last few years in
a certain way we're a typical denizens
of a great university because I suspect
that when this day is done you will have
heard more from us of you know up close
and personal concern about things like
sort of our connection to big popular
audiences market forces and so on and
even government intervention then you
will from people from elsewhere in the
University who engaged in the endeavors
they engage in so so the good and bad of
our job is worked out on the front lines
of politics and the marketplace and so
on more than most people in the
University on the other hand the
research university at least in the
United States was invented right around
the same time as the kind of journalism
informational objective non perspectival
that ideal in journalism was invented at
just about the same time late 19th
century and into the early 20th century
and that isn't coincidental and and and
Joseph Pulitzer had the idea of locating
a great school of journalism in a great
University at the same time his crusade
to start our school lasted from the
early 1890s into the beginning of the
20th century and then the school opened
in 1912 everybody here is wrestling with
some of the same problems versions of
the notion that a research university
began in a moment of total confidence
about expertise and authority and has
spent much of the last you know quarter
century and more being really challenged
on that notion of itself is there such a
thing as disinterested scholarship is
there such a thing as expertise should
the state the public look to the kind of
folks who sit in universities who are
you know hold themselves up often as
disinterested purveyors of information
with as figures to respect conversely
should we as people in universities
really try internally to hew to the idea
that we're completely neutral and
informational or are we allowed to be
political actors and if so when it's
it's these are questions that can keep
you up at night but it's fun to be in a
location where they're just being
addressed by everybody they're the most
vital questions of our time and it's
very enriching as a journalist to know
that we're not the only ones who have
these problems and to kind of cross
pollinate with other people who have
their very different versions of these
problems and try to come up with answers
from where we said the best thing we can
do at our school I think is one piece of
the puzzle which is try to create a very
strong sense of Professional Standards
this doesn't mean and it would be
impossible in the age of the web trying
to keep people out of being journalists
but it does mean trying to maintain both
skills and habits of thinking and
notions of professional conduct that
would enable us to function in the role
of information providers in a way that
can really be trusted and that I would
hope and dream can transcend the kinds
of local and national perspectives that
we saw it at the beginning of this piece
so that's what we're trying to do and
whether will succeed remains to be seen
but it's fun to have that as your as
your job description I will start
reading questions
depending on how good the handwriting it
okay with newspapers closing their
foreign bureaus and getting
international news from the wires what
is the impact on the quality of
reporting when there are fewer
journalists on the ground this is a
signed question from a Columbia
Journalism school grade but I think I
said at the outset I wasn't going to
announce the names so so i'll spare you
but who would like to take that on well
it's personal it's obviously i assume
written from a kind of American point of
view the foreign bureaus I assume were
talkin bout here are the outposts
outside the United States of America
news organizations and it's a worrisome
process for the mainly for the reason
that we discussed at the very beginning
because in order to have a broader view
of the world in order to punch holes in
your own paradigms you got to be hearing
from people outside and if you've
brought them all home you can have a lot
more trouble hearing you know there are
several really excellent wire services
and they do a very good job and on many
stories there their work is not just
adequate but but excellent in every
newspaper everywhere is on earth relies
on them some of the time but the retreat
from international coverage by American
news organizations is a worrisome as a
worrisome phenomenon it really tough
part of that question at least in terms
of the conversations I have is if you're
the Dallas Morning News and you say why
do I have to have a Paris Bureau or a
London bureau my my readers don't care
very much other news organizations have
them it's it's replicative what is the
public good that's served by my
maintaining that Bureau and you know you
can make the argument that the more
replication of function there is the
healthier it is I mean the obvious place
for Americans would be in Washington you
want to have a whole bunch of people
sitting there and bushes press
conference it's not just one person but
it's very hard for people to make those
economic decisions to maintain an
an expensive Bureau that doesn't seem on
mission for a local newspaper and that's
a completely reasonable discussion you
know if you're if you're a Dallas
newspaper your most important quote
unquote forum Bureau is obviously Mexico
City and and you have to make choices
obviously in different parts of the
country have different relationships to
the rest of the world but if everybody
retreats we're really losing something
next question traditionally leading
mainstream media have counted on their
brand is their advantage in the
fragmented world of new media but
YouTube has built a brand in three years
al-jazeera built a brand in five years
or the MSM for the uninitiated that
means mainstream media deluding
themselves on how they'll compete in the
future I think that we live in a very
very fast world with the Internet and
the emotional news from all different
channels but I think over time things
find their own niche like YouTube is a
niche it's true that even in Turkey a
lot of people are relying on YouTube to
get the news that for this reason or
that reason is not shown in the regular
media so i think that the traditional
mainstream news media will continue how
to have a large impact on the big
picture but there will be niche
organizations that are either reactive
like Al Jazeera i believe is kind of an
antidote to and maybe CNN or fox news so
the reactive the people who are reacting
to the way large media organizations are
presenting the news are forming other
blocks or there are niche opportunities
presented by the internet like youtube
so these are interesting points that
some of the main players may get into in
the future but they will also carve
little parts out of the mainstream media
in my opinion I think
becoming I don't think the mainstream
media is kidding itself or complacent I
see the opposite mainstream really
terrified by what's happening and I mean
we did a survey a year or so ago that
showed globally the fourth most highly
valued a respected news brand in the
world was Google and at that time Google
produced no journalism at all all they
did was aggregate everybody else's so
that is pretty terrifying if you are
investing you know hundreds of millions
of pounds in editorial resources and
someone with an algorithm is stealing
your your place in the world but you
know the truth is we are going to go
through a shakedown and some big brands
are going to disappear and they're going
to be some new brands that come in and
if you work for the BBC or the New York
Times or NBC you know we spend all our
time working out how do we reinforce our
position what is our new role how do we
provide value to our audience in a way
that they're going to you know really
want it and continue that relationship
with even and that's what the job of
those of us running news organizations
is of them in it's a strategic role a
quality brand a good name is a statement
of what the audience thinks about what
you've been and in this world that lasts
exactly a minute and then it's what
you're going to be that matters and if
you do believe that you can rest just on
your brand then you truly are deluded
the good news is if you're deluded like
that you'll be gone pretty fast and we
won't have to talk about you anymore I
have to say you know al Jazeera's has
been pointed out as a state system of
support YouTube is in terms of all these
markets a very sobering example as some
of you may have heard Dean's have to
fundraise a little bit and so I at one
point went to see a former reporter for
Time magazine who is now a silicon
valley venture capitalist and funded
YouTube and he told me that at the time
I was sold to google for how many
billions of dollars it was they didn't
even have an office they had a staff of
three and they were working in a spare
conference room at this particular
venture capital company and this man
said to me with great pleasure that's
the economic future of journalism so the
that's why I personally and don't feel
it's an automatic thing that the market
will support large reporting staffs
necessarily to real challenge that's why
we've all been nice to you today because
we need a teaching job please speak to
the effect of new problems with safety
of journalists especially killing of
Japanese photojournalist in Burma that
which is just very recent but there been
many others somebody yeah I earlier this
year I'm on the board of an organization
called the International new safety
institute and we produced a report which
looked back over the killing of
journalists over the last 10 years and
there are two things about that an
average of two journalists have been
killed doing their work every week week
in week out for the last 10 years but
the trend is getting worse i think last
year it was about 160 journalists were
killed doing their job this year i think
he looks like it's going to be worse
still so the trend is up there are a
number of issues lying behind that part
of it is the loss of neutrality actually
journalists are no longer recognized as
being neutral players they're simply
associated with the country they come
from there therefore more likely to be
targets it's the nature of conflict
these days and you have to look at Iraq
and other places in the Middle East to
see how how risky it is and all news
organizations are having to invest very
heavily in the training and safety of
their staff to maintain a team in
Baghdad costs us tens of millions of
pounds
every year and that is a real challenge
so there isn't a very positive message I
could put out of this except to say it's
a real issue it's getting more difficult
and it's very expensive and one of the
things we're trying to do is to get
recognition for those states that don't
pursue those who murdered journalists
doing their job and there is a problem
of impunity and a culture of impunity in
many countries and if at least we can
get international pressure to say you
know impunity for killing journalists is
not acceptable it would be a first start
and you pick this is a question directed
at you so I'll just give it to you you
can read it hello the women report of or
tell stories differently is it harder to
be a woman in the newsroom and top one I
mean I think there's the general
stereotype that I sometimes have heard
the news room that we would like to look
at the the emotional side or the history
/ of / topic more than the man but I I
think for the most part it really
doesn't matter and women tend to have
maybe more interest in some issues
because they face them like issues
relating to women's empowerment or
issues relating to women's rights
especially in societies like turkey or
in other emerging markets they're more
sensitive to these issues perhaps but I
see for the most part really not a huge
difference between the way we handle the
news but this is up to the audience to
decide following the cartoon crisis in
February 2006 where satiric drawings of
Mohammed published in a Danish newspaper
caused violent outrage throughout the
Islamic world Islamic organizations
demanded a quote limitations unquote and
a new set of ethics please comment on
the advantage disadvantage of such
limitations on freedom of speech okay
let me start I mean I think this is a
really complicated
and very challenging for those
particularly in international journalism
as we are my starting point would be to
say that we do have responsibilities in
terms of other cultures and that freedom
of speech is not the same as free and
easy speech it doesn't mean that
anything goes so in terms of the
cartoons around for example it was
obviously a very reportable issue within
the BBC we were pretty careful not to
show all of the cartoons but we did
communicate what they showed and why
they were offensive in other words we
tried to draw a line that meant we were
as open with all of our audiences about
what these cartoons were and what they
showed but we also showed some restraint
in seeking not to pour petrol on the
fire or to offend any of our Muslim
audience and I think there are
responsibilities there and and you know
this is going this is already very
complicated it may get more complicated
as you go on but I would say that I
think people who try to say freedom of
speech means anything goes wrong we have
responsibilities that have to go
alongside that and one of the factors
that goes into how you manage this kind
of a question is having the resources in
your own newsroom the diverse resources
as we were discussing earlier so that
you have people who can help make a
judgment most newspapers in the modern
world would not countenance running an
anti-semitic cartoon so therefore you
have to have people who can make the
distinction between a politically
powerful cartoon about some issue
affecting the Islamic world which would
be legitimate to publish and an
anti-muslim cartoon and that means you
have to have people who understand those
issues so I'd like to comment on this
this was a very very hot topic in in
Turkey and it was widely argued and
basically I think it's important once
the cartoons were out the handling of
the cartoons by the newspaper and by the
Danish authorities i think is as
important in its delicacy and in taking
into issue although all the different
varieties of reactions as the fact that
it was a mistake
perhaps that they were there in the
first place but it could have been
handled better in which case maybe the
crisis could have been more contained or
more palatable to Muslims I should also
say this issue has come up a little for
us at the school because the editor who
ran the cartoons Fleming Rose has been
sort of hiding out in New York somewhat
in plain sight in the salmon rushdie
manner and he's been in our school a lot
and he comes to visit he speaks to
classes and so on which i think is very
interesting for students but we have not
put him up on a stage and had a big
announced public event which may or may
not be the wrong the right call I just
sort of mentioned that that these issues
are constantly presenting themselves and
there's obviously security concerns etc
with that this is one other aspect to
that realm which is of course the summer
send it was staged I mean the BBC
reported those cartoons in previous
October nobody noticed or cared or was
watching but it was the particular
moment and they've been published in
Egyptian newspapers I think so there was
a particular group of mothers or
whatever who wanted to make an issue of
it and decided to make an issue of it
and then it took off and became this
kind of global thing but when you get
these issues you have to look quite
carefully up why is it come to public
attention at that moment whose interest
is it to have that kind of Rao at that
moment there's quite a lot of agendas
playing in the background to that it's
not always as straightforward as it
appears I guess this will be the last
question because we're right up against
the end how has u.s. journalism changed
under Bush
it's gotta be you Mike I'm here how
would I know